so
so
we are pure potential
infinite possibility
singularity
this earth simulator
being
a manifestation
of that
one of infinite possibility
being explored
by a singularity
using consciousness as
the power to know
enlightenment awakening
is the realization of this
i and all this is
the ineffable absolute
when you've deconditioned
from all
separation
hmm
and you relax
into the truth
of being that pure potential
that singularity
at play with itself
in this earth simulator manifestation
you surrender into the divinity
you have faith
in the freedom and perfection
that it all already and always
is
so much joy
so much peace
so much gratitude
and so much non-attachment
as the separation deconditions
the non-attachment kicks in
and you can truly shepherd
reality awakening
from the purest place possible
rather than acting from
the place of wanting to be seen
as a separate person
to validate all of the conditioning
you come from the place of pure
potential
from the place of the singularity
and you see everything
as that
and you hold naturally
abide harmoniously
in that very empty infinitude
in that very awakened state
and the shepherding the stewarding
the service from there
is unparalleled it's the purest
it's the highest
total non-attachment total
deconditioning from separation
is the goal
total abiding awakening
as the one intelligence at play with
itself
locked in
being very vigilant
as the catalyst appears of when
that separate conditioning
arises and to very
lovingly radically accept
and love it exactly as it is
and just with that awareness love light
and the surrender
it dissolves and further
and further we lock in
that pure potential that
conscious singularity
[Music]
[Music]
so
the most simple
trick is to slow down
the very act of slowing down
is in itself trust
faith conviction
surrender
[Music]
and as you slow down
you notice more
you become more aware
of awareness
you become more conscious of
consciousness
and you stop perpetually habitually
overlooking it to try and get
peace and happiness out of objects
and experiences and relationships and
substances
as you slow down
you also
are able to
more frictionlessly
navigate
the deconditioning of separation
so you slow down and what used to be
a trigger that would come and you
wouldn't even know
you wouldn't be conscious of how it
would create
a sensation that would then trigger
this big web of conditioning
that it would then pinball
around creating so much suffering
when you slow down you watch as what
used to be a trigger
come as a sensation
that dissolves into emptiness
and immediately you're liberated from it
you're back to that pure potentiality
that freedom
and over time as you continue slowing
down
you'll notice that web of conditioning
of separation
dissolves
you reclaim
recognize
your true nature
as god the conscious
singularity pure potentiality
empty infinity the natural state
all conditioning and separation
is unnatural
it's insanity
[Music]
[Music]
we as the creator
created the
conditioning of separation
to act as a pressure cooker
for awakening
and so we radically love and accept
the conditioning separation
because we know that it is
the very drill sergeant of awakening
itself the very sledgehammer
of suffering that creates
the turn inward
and we recognize how insane
ego separation and all of that
conditioning
that we've built up over decades
is
as we reclaim and recognize
absolute freedom absolute perfection
the very natural state
of knowing
that this is all a manifestation
of eternity
of the pure potentiality
of the singularity that we are
and to truly
pierce both emptiness and
infinity is key
as you pierce consciousness awareness
pierce emptiness infinity
and this leads to the abiding
awakening
infinite love
thank you
you